[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings an oklahoma
man is just hours away from being
executed unless the governor steps in
julius jones was sentenced to death
almost 20 years ago for the murder of
paul howell it happened in 1999 when
jones was 19 years old he's always
maintained his innocence but howe's
family believes jones is responsible and
deserves to die last night the state
police arrested one of the protesters
gathered outside the governor's mansion
urging him to grant jones clemency maria
bial is at the state capitol in oklahoma
city where she spoke to jones's sister
maria good morning
hey good morning nate earlier this month
the oklahoma parole board actually
recommended that jones's sentence be
commuted and that he'd be given life in
prison with the possibility of parole
but ultimately the power lies with the
governor and as time continues to
dwindle down very quickly jones family
continues to beg the governor to spare
his life
this is a state of emergency this is a
man's life on the line his life has been
on the line for 22 years
for something he did not do
antoina jones knows time is running out
to save her brother her family visited
him in prison wednesday for what could
be the last time how was that
it was very hard in the in the fact that
i wanted to hug my brother and that i
haven't hugged my brother
17 years
what did julius tell you today
the most important thing he said was for
us to keep living
he said for us not to be angry if they
do
go forth with the execution
but he said to keep
talking about him talking about his
truth talking about the truth of the
case
so that this does not happen to anybody
else
did he still have hope
he still has hope on july 28 1999 paul
howell was murdered outside his parents
edmond oklahoma home in front of his
family his suv was stolen and a witness
reported seeing a black man with a red
bandana and one to two inches of hair
shoot the father of two three days later
nineteen-year-old julius jones was
arrested his family says eyewitness
descriptions did not match julius who at
the time had a shaved head they also say
he was home at the time of the murder
[Music]
wednesday his mother surrounded by
supporters pleaded for his release the
truth will set you free we talk about
justice justice for whom
justice for all of us
earlier this month oklahoma's pardon and
parole board recommended his sentence be
commuted asking the governor to change
it to life in prison with the
possibility of parole the board chairman
said i believe in death penalty cases
there should be no doubt and put simply
i have doubts in this case i am not the
person responsible for taking mr house
life but paul howell's family says
that's not true we spoke to howell's
daughter rachel before the board made
their clemency recommendation i want to
be a voice for my dad because
he was an innocent man
taking his kids to get ice cream with my
aunt and he was murdered
in front of me and my sister and my aunt
all for a car
and he never got a say in this there's
overwhelming amount of evidence of his
guilt julius jones fate is now in the
hands of oklahoma's republican governor
kevin stitt who so far has only met with
the howell family this is the first
death row clemency case he's faced
antoinette says she'll be at the prison
later today will you go inside
i have to i have to be there for my
brother
i would want him to be there for me
you're taking a lot on yourself
why
because he's worth it his life is worth
it his life has always been worth the
fight
police have set up barricades at the
governor's mansion just in case there's
any unrest we've seen a number of extra
troopers brought here to the state
capitol there are expected rallies at
the prison as well as here at in
oklahoma city if the governor does
nothing right now the execution will go
as planned it's set for 4 p.m
central time gail
maria this is a heartbreaking story on
so many levels thank you so much listen
we're all very sorry that paul howe lost
his life
that's the main thing but number two
there still seem to be so many questions
you have the parole board chairman
saying that he has doubts in the case
i don't understand why the governor said
he'll meet with the why he will not meet
with the jones family when he's met with
the howell family yeah it's a lot to
process the expert's sitting here but
the people who've looked at the case
closely seem to have doubts and that
should go a long way but but you're
right i mean it's heinous the crime but
yeah also heinous to put to death a
person who may not have done it yeah and
not to be dismissive to the victim's
family like you're saying we understand
that but when the parole bird parole
board is speaking out it's almost like
when do you decide not to listen to them
yeah because in other instances you
listen to every word that they have to
say about cases you know my first
thought was for the victims and the
victim's family questions looking at
julius jones and there's too many
questions here there's doubt